>> Martha: ANYTHING BUT SECURE.
THANKS, BELL.
NOW, MOMENTS AGO, THE WHITE
HOUSE REPEATEDLY SAYING IT'S
TIME FOR CONGRESS TO FIX THE
BROKEN SYSTEM.
WITH THAT WE BRING IN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL WALTZ.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY.
I WANT TO START WITH THIS FROM
MOMENTS AGO IN THE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING ROOM, THIS IS THE PRESS
SECRETARY, KARINE JEAN-PIERRE.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE MIGRANTS ARE BEING USED
AS POLITICAL PAWNS.
IT'S RECKLESS.
JUST PLAIN WRONG.
THESE ARE PEOPLE FLEEING
COMMUNISM, FLEEING HARDSHIP.
>> Martha: CONGRESSMAN, WELCOME.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
TONIGHT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE?
THIS IS ABOUT AN HOUR AGO.
>> THANKS, MARTHA.
I WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT IS
SHAMEFUL?
WHAT IS WRONG?
FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, KAMALA HARRIS TO
SAY THE BORDER IS SECURE.
IT'S A LIE.
ANYBODY WITH COMMON SENSE CAN
SEE AND THEN TO SAY WE'RE GOING
AFTER THE ROOT CAUSES ASKING FOR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARSES TO GO TO
CENTRAL AMERICA WHERE THE
CARTELS TAKE 20 TO 30% AND THE
CORRUPT GOVERNMENTS TAKE 20 TO
30%.
YOU'RE FEEDING THE PROBLEM IN TO
A NEGATIVE SPIRAL THAT IS MAKING
IT WORSE.
ON THE GOVERNORS, LOOK, THIS IS
AN ISSUE OF FAIRNESS, MARTHA.
WHY IS IT FAIR FOR ALL OF THESE
BORDER CITIES, THE UVALDES, THE
SAN ANTONIOS, EL PASOS TO HAVE
TO ABSORB THIS CRISIS, WHETHER
IT'S HOSPITALS, SCHOOLS, ROADS
AND BRIDGES, BUT ALL OF THESE
CITIES IN CHICAGO, MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, BOSTON, NEW YORK,
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
THIS IS A BASIC ISSUE OF
FAIRNESS.
THEY'RE FEELING JUST A FRACTION
OF THE PAIN THAT ALL OF OUR
BORDER CITIES AND BORDER STATES
HAVE BEEN FEELING.
>> Martha: I'M SO STRUCK BY THE
HYPOCRISY OF THIS WHOLE THING.
BECAUSE THESE INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE BORDER, THEY'VE BEEN BE
BEING SENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FOR A LONG TIME.
WE SPOKE IN APRIL TO A
REPRESENTATIVE IN NEW YORK.
WHEN HE WAS UPSET ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON WITH PLANES LANDING IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT, NONE OF
THESE SAME GOVERNORS SAID
ANYTHING.
THEY WERE NOT UPSET.
WATCH THIS IN APRIL.
>> SECRET FLIGHTS WERE COMING
FROM TEXAS TO WESTCHESTER
AIRPORT IN THE DEAD OF NIGHT.
I WAS ASKING QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A LETTER THAT I SENT
FEBRUARY 1 TO THE PRESIDENT
WANTING TO KNOW WHO IS COMING
IN, WHERE THEY'RE BEING PLACED,
IF THERE'S KIDS AND SOME OF THEM
ARE AND WHAT SCHOOLS.
WHAT IS PAYING FOR THIS?
WE ARE, THE TAXPAYERS.
>> Martha: SO I DON'T REMEMBER
REPRESENTATIVES FROM MARTHA'S
VINEYARD OR D.C. OR MANHATTAN,
ANY OF THEM BEING UPSET WHEN HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT IT,
CONGRESSMAN.
>> YEAH.
THOSE ARE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TAX-PAYER FUNDED CONTRACTS WITH
A NUMBER OF NGOs FLYING THESE
PEOPLE IN THE DEAD OF NIGHT TO
ALL OF THESE SAME LOCATIONS.
THEN IT'S FINE.
IF YOU HAVE GOVERNOR DESANTIS OR
ABBOTT OR DOOCY DOING IT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DAY WHERE
EVERYBODY CAN SEE IT, THEN WE'RE
UP IN ARMS, WE'RE HAVING A
COLLECTIVE POLITICAL MELTDOWN.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS THIS IS
FOR ALL OF THE TAXPAYERS TO SEE
RATHER THAN SNEAKING THEM IN.
EITHER WAY, ALL OF THE SERVICES
THAT AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS DESERVE ARE
NOW BEING TAXED BY MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT WE JUST
CAN'T AFFORD TO FEED AND HOUSE
AND CLOTHE THE ENTIRE WORLD.
>> Martha: YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
SEX TRAFFICKING AND THE DRUGS
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER THAT
BILL MELUGIN REPORTS ON EVERY
DAY.
I DON'T SEE IT ON OTHER
NETWORKS.
BUT WHAT IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
DOING ABOUT THOSE ROOT CAUSES?
I MEAN, IT'S OKAY TO MOVE PEOPLE
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO SHARE THE
BURDEN.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS YOU HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF GOT-AWAYS AND
DRUGS THAT NOBODY IS DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IN WASHINGTON.
>> YOU WANT THE ROOT CAUSES,
TAKE ON THE CARTELS.
THIS SHOULD BE THE TOP OF THE
AGENDA WITH CHINA WHO PRODUCES
FENTANYL.
BY THE WAY, WE SHOULD
REINSTITUTE TO REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY WHILE THESE PEOPLE WAIT
FOR THEIR ASYLUM PAPERS.
TOES ARE ROOT CAUSES.
INSTEAD, WE HAVE A MASSIVE
INCENTIVIZATION SYSTEM FOR
PEOPLE TO MAKE THIS DANGEROUS
JOURNEY.
30 TO 40% OF THE GIRLS THAT MAKE
IT ARE SOLD IN TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OR SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED.
THAT IS WRONG.
>> Martha: IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
TRAGICALLY UNDERCOVERED STORIES
IN THIS WHOLE THING.
WE HAVE COVERED IT AND WE WANT
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO SHED LIGHT
ON IT.
I KNOW YOU HAVE, TOO.
IT'S ATROCIOUS THAT IT'S
HAPPENING IN THI